sir Ernest shackleton's Imperial trans
Antarctic expedition was one of
history's most daring and challenging
voyages but when the endurance was
crushed by Ice Shackleton and his crew
were forced to abandon ship and begin a
perilous journey to safety shackleton's
leadership was crucial to their survival
he kept his crew motivated and focused
on their goal even when they were faced
with insurmountable odds shackleton's
Voyage is a testament to the power of
leadership resilience and teamwork here
are three business lessons you can apply
from his story be honest and transparent
with your team Shackleton never
sugarcoated the challenges they faced he
told his crew the truth even when it was
hard lesson two put the needs of your
crew first Shackleton was always
courteous and more concerned with the
crew safety than his own personal goals
lesson three never give up even when
things look hopeless Shackleton and his
crew faced many setbacks in their
Journey but they never gave up hope they
kept fighting until they reached their
destination Shack's Voyage is a reminder
that anything is possible if you have
the courage to lead and the strength to
persevere